okay so hello and welcome everybody
i warmly welcome you to the session of
ceramics club titled applying
transcriptomics gene expression data
analysis
for neuroscience project so
for the presenters today we have
urja parikh she was omixlogic research
fellow in 2020
she did her bs in biomedical sciences
from
svkms managemongi institute of
management studies
the project she did was differential
identification of biomarkers between
normal
neural stem cells and glioblastoma stem
cells
after completing her project she went
ahead and published her paper the
picture you can see over here so
i warmly welcome you urja and the second
presenter for today
is nitra srinivasan she was also a
mixologic research fellow in 2020 she is
a student at leland high school
and the project title is effects of
onset of menopause on transcriptomics
profiling a female brain
so first udra will present followed by
nathra's presentation but before
starting with the presentations
i would like to brief you all about what
cyanics club is
so cyanics is a bioinformatics and data
science student club
which is a joint initiative taken by
students associated with pine biotech
our main goal is to help students learn
about bioinformatics research via group
sessions
easy to take courses debates and
discussions
we not only do this but also aim to
encourage
young minds to push their critical
thinking limits beyond the school and
college curriculum
i am rudy raja president of cyanics club
and also serving as a campus ambassador
at pine biotech
i am an undergraduate third year student
of integrated biomedical
sciences for the last session in the
last week we did an astrobiology session
which was again presented by our
research fellows that is subrajit
and dilara de ken they presented the
projects on astrobiology
for today's session we i as already
discussed we have urja and natra to
present on neuroscience project uses
using transcriptomics gene expression
data analysis
for further on what do we do in our
weekly ceramics club meeting
is that we have interactive zoom
sessions we have debates and we discuss
certain kinds of
review report writing or certain kinds
of crucial health topics which could be
important in bioinformatics big data
analysis
so our main goal is to provide training
in bioinformatics
enable independent research that is
guided by mentors and pure example
not only this but we also wish to
develop a growing community full of
students researchers and even mentors
for the data-driven research and
appreciation of science citizen science
we also help enable students clinicians
and faculties of
all the backgrounds of life sciences and
bioinformatics to develop
novel and independent research projects
using latest technology
in life and data sciences
we cover topics like infectious diseases
neuroscience
plant science prescription oncology
microbes and microbiome
this helps us to apply the knowledge
of application of big data into biology
not only this but we also help
students clear basic concepts of
bioinformatics in our weekly sessions
we help them to gain insight onto how to
use the tools of
bioinformatics by demonstrating live
hands-on experiments
we also help them understand the
applications of coding and
bioinformatics and certain specific
experience on data science skill sets
so for to begin with your journey for
cyanics club
and with pine biotech you need to make
an account on omixlogic whose link would
be shortly shared in the chat box
once you this is like a home page of
omics logic where you
need to enter your email id and then the
password
we also have social groups on psionics
club that is on slack channel
we have omics logic groups on linkedin
and also on facebook the links will be
shared in the chat box
moving on we also provide free courses
that is introduction to bioinformatics
and introduction to genomics
these are self-learning courses easy to
take without paying
anything and one can learn the basics of
bioinformatics by enrolling themselves
into these course
furthermore we also offer premium
courses like bioinformatics machine
learning
genomics transcriptomics meta genomics
and machine learning
so these are premium courses which you
have to pay some amount in order to
learn
but we provide these courses at very
cheap rates
and they are very useful if you want to
get started with bioinformatics
we also have group discussions as talked
about in which we have to bet on
mind-boggling arenas and certain crucial
topics in bioinformatics
we have presentations by phd scholars
research fellows
of all their research work or their
published work
and we also have scientific discussions
and debates in order to exchange the
ideas for project development and
further research and development
as told you can connect with us on the
slack channel
that is the psionics channel over here
we help
everyone to get know about the latest
upcoming events
webinars and everything we also have
linkedin group for
pine biotech where we post about most of
the upcoming sessions
and webinars we also have our telegram
group in which we talk about
the upcoming members upcoming webinars
and everything
and for the slack channel we also have
omics logic research fellowship slack
channel in which we
discuss the technical criteria of the
project
so everyone who is doing a research or
is a research fellow associated with
find biotech
can join this omics logic research
fellowship slack channel in which we
discuss the technical part of it if
someone is having any problems
encountering in their
way of project and further on and how to
join the cyanomix club this is the
whatsapp group link you can
you join the club using this whatsapp
group link and also we welcome all the
ages because we think that knowledge has
no boundaries
thank you very much for listening this
patiently
i mean right now urja to share her
screen and start with her presentation
ujja over to you thank you
thank you so much victory for that kind
introduction
and um i'm so happy to see how much
fine bio has grown and fiomix is a great
initiative
to spread information about
bioinformatics
and i can personally attest to the fact
that bioinformatics is extremely useful
in biology
and it will take every student ahead
in their academic future so it will put
you at the top
amongst other students so um i'll share
my screen now
and i hope my presentation is visible
yes urjah it is visible thank you okay
so um last year i was a research fellow
with pine biotech
um and the title of my project was
different initially but
this is the final title with which we
have also released our paper
which is in silicon analysis and
characterization of differentially
expressed genes
to distinguish glioma stem cells from
normal human stem cells
so uh it it sounds quite complex but i
will
yeah just a minute i'm so sorry to
interrupt can you just on your video
because we are live on youtube
okay sure thank you hold on a second
okay i hope i'm visible yes good to go
awesome right
okay right so i will break down uh
the aspects of this research project for
you all to understand
uh but before i proceed i'll just speak
a little bit about myself
i recently completed my master's in
biomedical science
from sunandan deveter school of science
which is a part of the nmins university
in mumbai
i'm currently working at a hospital in
mumbai which is
hospital and i'm involved in several
research projects here
i'm also a visiting research fellow at
blue marble space institute of science
uh i'm working remotely at the moment
and this
particular non-profit organization is
based out of
the us so um
coming to my research underwater in 2016
i began my undergrad studies in
biomedical science where
i was introduced to vast areas of
biology including neurobiology cell
biology molecular biology
by a lot of these subjects
and um it was neuroscience that uh
really
elicited my interest so after that
in 2018 i interned at st
viewers college which is again in mumbai
where i
was involved in two research projects in
one i
identified two novel strains of leaves
and characterized them and in the other
i created a puc 18 vector which has a
team binding domain from yeast
in my final year of graduation undergrad
i also synthesize nanoparticles using a
plant extract
in 2020 um i had actually lost a very
important research fellowship which was
supposed to happen in canada
and that's when i actually searched for
pine biotech
and i remotely interned with them for
the period of three months and that's
when i
performed this particular analysis and
now
i'm working at uh hospital as i said
where i have completed my master's
thesis and i'm working on establishing
two proteins s100b and gfap as
biomarkers for diseases like
intracellular hematoma and traumatic
brain injury
um i've also established a machine
learning algorithm that diagnoses acute
kidney injury in patients
um and now further i also wish to pursue
a phd
so coming to my project um please feel
free to ask me any questions in the chat
i will come back to those uh
after the presentations done so let's
talk about glioblastoma multiform which
is
gbm um this particular type of brain
cancer is a primary brain tumor which is
extremely malignant
extremely aggressive and a patient who
gets this particular type of cancer has
an overall survival period of only 15
months post therapy
so it's difficult uh to increase their
survival time
and that is mostly going to um the
etiology of this cancer so
scientists still don't know where this
cancer is arising from
all right so we know the uh place which
is the subventricular zone in the brain
uh where these particular type of
cancers usually originate but how is
what is unknown so currently there are
two hypotheses
uh that tell us about the origin of
glioblastoma
one states that normal neural stem cells
can accumulate mutations
undergo transformation and form this
particular type of cancer
the second hypothesis states that cancer
stem cells
are tumor initiating cells that may
directly
cause the origin of this particular type
of cancer so now this particular these
two hypotheses have been widely debated
since years it is also important to
understand that cancer stem cells
also impart radio resistance and chemo
resistance in these particular types of
cancers so glioblastoma
is popularly known for its recurrence so
after the first tumor has been treated
the tumor tends to relapse and come back
again
uh and these particular types of
secondary tumors are more radio
resistant
uh and therefore difficult to treat
so what is as i said what is unknown is
what are the differences or what are the
similarities between cancer stem cells
and in this
case we will call the cancers themselves
gliomas themselves
also also abbreviated as gse
so are glioma stem cells similar to
normal neural stem cells or are they
different
it is essential to understand the
differences between these two types of
stem cells
uh because if we identify genetic and
epigenetic differences
we can also understand what exactly is
the reason why glioblastoma is malignant
and we can also target particular
proteins or genes
that may be the most important in
driving this particular type of cancer
so using precision medicine we will be
able to improve therapeutic efficacy
and therefore in order to answer the
question whether they are similar or
different
we have performed rna sleep analysis to
identify the genetic differences between
uh normally on stem cells and biomass
themselves
so how have we done this the first step
in rna seep analysis
is to collect data because of course
this
is not a wet lab project this is done on
a computer so we have to find existing
databases
and existing data sets to perform our
experiment
so there is um a website or a database
which is called
geogeo which is a part of ncbi
uh so on this particular database you
get it's a depository of rna sequences
where you get different types of rna
samples are any sequence samples of
different types of cancers
or different types of organisms so you
go on this particular database and you
have to go
through multiple projects to see which
one fits your criteria the best
so i fortunately found a great data data
set of rna sequences
uh in which the person had
isolated rna sequence from glioma stem
cells as well as normal neural stem
cells
so that the particular code for this
particular data set was gsc1c2172
which you can actually go check on the
internet
now they had a sample size of 188
samples however
because the data is too large we only
selected 40 samples
20 of glioma stem cells and 20 of normal
stem cells
the next step is to take this rna
sequence and make sense of
it and we do that using rna seed
analysis
right so we analyze data using certain
pipelines
so uh this entire analysis has been done
on the pine biotech
platform so what you essentially do is
you take the rna sequence that you
obtained from the internet
and you align these particular rna
sequences
to the human genome at the end of this
you get
the gene counts of every gene that has
been expressed in
either glioma stem cells and normal
neural stem cells and after that
in order to understand how differently
certain genes are expressed in these two
types of
uh stem cell samples you perform
differential
gene expression analysis and for that
you use a pipeline called dc2
so this is like the general idea of what
rna seek analysis is
then once you have got the abundance of
gene
uh expression in these two types of
samples and once you know
how differently they are expressed in
these two types of stem cells you have
to perform gene ontology
studies which basically means that uh
you have
um identified certain genes that are of
importance
but you need to understand what their
functions are so i will of course be
talking about more
about this in more detail so coming to
the results
so after performing the rna sleep
pipeline as i already showed you
we started with a total of 27 385 genes
at the beginning
which were enriched in these two types
of stem cells now this is a large
it's a huge number of genes so we have
to uh
set certain thresholds to identify the
most significant genes that may be
playing a role in driving this
particular type of cancer
so um after you perform differential
gene expression analysis that gives you
an idea of what
genes are upregulated and downregulated
in these stem cells
you have to choose the significance
value which is usually lesser than 0.05
and you have to also look at the log to
full change value
so this uh is basically an indicator of
the abundance of gene expression
uh so for this a particular project we
kept it uh
greater than three for git and lesser
than minus three for nfcs i'll be
explaining that further
so from 27 385 genes we finally came
down to the top
50 most significant genes that might be
involved in
driving glioblastoma multiple so
once you have got the uh gene expression
uh from or the gene abundance from the
rna seq analysis the first step that you
have to do
is uh principal component component
analysis which is a type of
dimensionality reduction
um where you i so basically in these
graphs you can see that glioma stem
cells and normally your stem cells have
separated and clustered quite apart from
each other which basically
shows that these two types of stem cells
are indeed
different in terms of their genetic
expression
right so that was a first clue that
normal neural stem cells and gluomas
themselves are actually genetically
different
to confirm these findings we also
perform the type of
machine learning algorithm which is
hierarchical clustering
over here again we confirm that normally
your stem cells cluster together
glioma stem cells cluster together we
also found an important outlier sample
now this outline sample was actually a
glioma stem cell sample
which actually clustered in between
normal stem cells and glioma stem cells
um we believe that this particular
outlier sample might be an important
clue about how normal neural stem cells
can actually transform to glioma stem
cells
because it technically lies in between
uh and
it might be uh giving us hints about the
transformation process
of stem like a normal use themselves to
a cancerous phenotype
the next thing that we did was perform
differential gene expression analysis
and uh
like after you run the pipeline you get
uh several types of graphs
so one of them is a volcano plot that
you can see on this particular slide
so you can see these dots that are in
blue
so they are genes that are highly
expressed in
either types of stem cell samples so um
as you can see there are so many genes
not all of them are the most significant
ones
so as i already mentioned to you that we
have to choose the most significant ones
and for that we use the p
adjusted value which is which is
supposed to be lesser than 0.05
and we also look at the log to fold
change value which tells us
what are the most um abundantly uh
differentially
expressed genes right so um over here
supposing you take normal neural stem
cells you see s hundred a 11 ubb
mg st1 so open f1 so these are the most
abundantly differentially expressed
genes that you may find in normal neural
stem cells and similarly in glioma stem
cells you have s hundred p s hundred
eighty rp1
which are more important candidates so
by setting these particular thresholds
we
identified 192 genes that were
significantly upregulated in glioma stem
cells and 156 genes
that was significantly downregulated in
glioma stem cells in comparison to
normal neural stem cells
so that is in total we had 348 gene
candidates
that may be important in driving glioma
genesis
so what do you do of these 348 genes
right so that's when gene ontology comes
in
so what we did was we took these
particular gene sets
that we had obtained from differential
gene expression analysis and loaded it
on
um david and geg so these two are
online repositories again where you can
upload your gene data
and it will provide you details about
where your genes are involved in what
kind of diseases in what kind of cell
signaling pathways what exactly the
function of the genes that you have got
in your subject
so what i saw with my results was that
the genes that i had identified were
mostly
enriched in diseases such as alzheimer's
schizophrenia adhd
autism myocardial infarction but there
was no involvement of these particular
genes
with glioma genesis which gives give
which gave us the first hint that uh the
genes that we have obtained
in our study are novel and their
indication in glymogenesis
has still not been studied so
um okay so over here you see that there
are
uh several uh pathways in which our
genes have been
involved so the ones that you can see
with the
star marked in red so these ankyl
is one protein that was found in my
particular gene list
which was shown to be enriched in um the
glioma stem cells
so this particular protein and iron is
responsible for cell growth migration
proliferation
um then we had sdc4 and alpha 2 beta 1
which is an integrin
which are responsible for angiogenesis
again and migration and pulsation
pathways
other integrins that were again involved
in tumor cell and invasion pathways
we saw the wind protein that was
enriched in a particular data set which
is
again responsible for proliferation and
survival of tumor cells
the wedges which is one of the most uh
common
uh angiogenesis factors that drives uh
tumor promotion
so we saw all these particular genes
were involved in
our particular gene cells again we had
tgf beta pathway so we had genes like
lumifan and caviolen which were
involved which drive apoptosis and
growth suppression which may be
upregulated or down regulated or mutated
in our particular types of stem cell
samples
so overall this basically shows that the
genes
that we obtained in our study are
identified in our study
are involved in several tumor genesis
pathways you might be knowing that
there are certain hallmarks of cancers
and these particular hallmarks of
cancers
are pathways by which tumors evade say
the immune cells or they continue growth
so
we have a clear indication that the
genes in my study are involved in the
hallmarks of cancers
so again 348 genes that we considered in
our study were again
too many so we again need to identify
the most important ones
so what i did was i filtered the only
top 15 most highly differentially
expressed genes
right so the ones that are more
abundantly expressed in either normal
stem cells or glioma stem cells those
are the ones that i considered
for further literature review
again using those top 50 genes that i
selected i again carried out principal
component analysis and saw
that the separation of glioma stem cells
and normal stem cells
is still vast and therefore they differ
significantly
considering these 50 genes and their
expression
and uh that the genes that are
upregulated in glioma stem cells are
downregulated in normally the stem cells
and the ones that are upregulated in
normal stem cells that are regulated in
glioma stem cells which you can see in
this heat map
so uh then what i did was i performed
the literature review of those 50 genes
and what i saw was that uh while we had
identified several candidates which have
an already known association in glioma
genocide
for example s100b gp and mb
which were up regulated in glioma stem
cells uh and there were genes like s
hundred a eleven u b
d so open f1 which were down regulated
in glioma stem cells
these genes have already been studied by
scientists
and have unknown involvement in this
particular type of cancer
but more importantly we find we found
genes
that have still no known studies
performed and
are actually if we study it more we will
actually find they are involved in
glioma genesis
so these genes which have more previous
known association with gluogenesis
are itm2a box one we also found
several unidentified genes so these are
completely normal genes
which have still not been discovered by
scientists so these particular genes
actually need to be
um studied in more detail by people who
are working in labs
and identify their roles um in glioma
genesis
so to conclude my findings i identify
348 significantly differentially
expressed genes
in glioma stem cells and normal neural
stem cells like with a stringent um
threshold values these genes that i
found in my pathways were involved in
uh hallmarks of cancers like tgf beta
wind signaling and angiogenesis pathway
i identified several genes that have
more than association with glioma
genesis and therefore are very good
candidates to study
in order to understand better how this
cancer progresses
in the brain um i believe that future
studies on these particular candidates
um
can reveal important targets for therapy
so they can act as good biomarkers for
either diagnosis or prognosis
or they can be targeted by a physician
medicine
finally the outlier sample that i
mentioned earlier
i think uh having more studies on that
particular type of samples would reveal
hints
uh regarding how normally your stem
cells can transform to
glioma stem cells or directly to the
cancerous phenotype
uh so yeah so those were the results of
my studies and
these are just three most important
differences in my study
um at this point i would like to
acknowledge uh the entire team at pine
biotech
uh dr mohit mazumdar uh
who have been extremely crucial in this
project
and uh for their help in supporting me
throughout
and i would also like to thank luther
and the entire cyomics team for
inviting me and allowing me to present
my work um i would also like to state
that
um i have presented this particular work
at several international and national
conferences
and i have won several awards for the
same
so yeah i think um fine biotech has been
so helpful in helping me develop my
own uh profile my research profile and
this particular
research study has also gained a lot of
accolades so i believe that
all of you all should learn
bioinformatics
because it's a great feel it's a very
interesting field
and if you're ever planning to apply for
a phd bioinformatics is a very crucial
skill to have
um so yeah i hope this um
session was helpful if you all have any
questions
i can answer them now and you can always
email me
on my email id which was mentioned here
thank you
urja that was an amazing presentation
and how significantly you have grown
makes me so happy to see how much you
have progressed and all
so thank you so much again for
presenting i had a question
that uh what exactly does need to be
studied for that
outlier in order to see the
transformation from neural to
glioblastoma
program prognosis right
um again um that's a great question
richard
uh one thing that we have not done in
this particular study
is um look at the genetic differences in
comparison to the
complete tumor population right so we
have only looked at stem cell
populations
uh if we compare this particular outlier
sample
along with the normal so normal
neurostem cell sample so this particular
outlier was a glioma stem cell sample
so what we can do is correlate the
genetic findings
with the normal you know stem cell
samples as well as the glioma
the actual tumor the entire tumor
instead of just looking at the
uh stem cells with that we will be able
to see how much
uh similarity is there in the genetic
expression uh how much is it close to
the glioblastoma phenotype and how much
is it close to the normal neural stem
cell
so we will actually be able to see uh
like a progression
of genetic changes so if in a normal
neurostem cell a particular gene
is not is downregulated
maybe in this particular outlier sample
it is mildly upregulated and maybe in
the cancers the entire cancerous
phenotype
uh if we compare that particular gene is
very highly upregulated
so we can actually see those kind of
differences and uh
understand whether um is it like
a progressive behavior in the pattern of
gene expression
that is one way to study it of course
there will be other ways to study
um outlier samples which i will actually
have to
uh look into but uh i can
get back to you on that for sure thanks
urja
we do have another question from he's
asking
he's telling great work and really
insightful and he has a question that
can you please elaborate the steps you
use to find the differentially
expression of genes thank you to that
so um okay let me just go back to that
slide
yeah so see after rna sleep analysis you
get
something called a gene count table okay
so
after that you are supposed to um
i'm talking only technically what you're
supposed to do is
uh you take the g income table and then
you have to actually normalize your
gene counts and you have to also remove
all the background noise that may be
there so
you have to quantile normalize it after
you have got
after you have processed your gene
counts you have to basically upload
those gene count
uh data onto the platform and you have
to run this pipeline
which is the differential gene
expression pipeline which is dc2
so what this pipeline essentially does
is uh tells us
how different is the expression of a
particular gene in comparison to the
control sample
so for example if glioma stem cell
i want to look at the expression of a
particular gene and glioma stem cell
my control would be a normal neural stem
cell so what happens in this particular
type of
pipeline you get how much more
is a particular gene expressed in the
glioma stem cell in comparison to normal
neural stem cells
right so um over here it's pretty
straight forward all you need to do is
uh
upload your gene pounds and then run
this particular pipeline
and after that after you
you get that particular pipeline you'll
again get like a huge uh
amount of data right so when you get
that data
you have to so you will get several
columns where you will have different
parameters of each gene
so if you have started with say um 27
000 genes
the after you run this particular
pipeline you will get only those
particular genes that are differentially
expressed
then when there is a difference in
expression of those genes
so what you will get along with each
gene is the p-value
so if your p-value is greater than 0.05
then that means that the difference in
gene expression is not significant
so you have to automatically eliminate
those particular genes
then the genes that uh have a
significant value less than 0.05
you need to consider those again you
will still end up with a lot of genes
so again you need to filter them then
you look at the log full change value
where you see the genes that are the
most
abundantly expressed in a particular
sample so
when you actually look at the data it
would be simpler for you to understand
what i'm saying
uh you have to select the highest values
in order to
identify only few genes that may be of
relevance i
hope i may made it slightly more clear
further then
one more last question we have from the
youtube
sharing uh so prima is asking what
exactly brain cells are transforming
into tumor cells i mean she means to
say that what types of brain cells are
transforming into
tumor cells okay so lima
good question or these are stem cells
so glioblastoma
currently the hypothesis are the
glioblastoma arises from stem cells
these stem cells are usually found in
the subventricular zone of the brain
right so even in a normal person who
does not have this cancer there are
a population of stem cells that are
present in that particular area of the
brain
um what happens in patients with
glioblastoma
these particular types of stem cells may
include
sorry wall
okay so um what i was saying was those
stem cells that are present in that
portion of the brain can
mutate and when a lot of mutations
accumulate
they can become cancerous um so that is
the current hypothesis around which we
believe that glioblastoma arises from
i hope that answers your question reema
yes thank you any more questions you can
put it down in the chat box uja will
answer
at the last once we finish natra's
presentation
thank you so much urja for sharing and
we definitely have a lot to learn from
you
thank you so much for having me i look
forward to natra's presentation
sure hi nidra can you hear me
hi are you able to hear me yes natra i
am a very warm welcome over here and we
are glad to have you
thank you finally yeah so can you please
share your screen and go ahead with your
presentation
yes thank you
all right are you able to see my uh
slides
yes i just visible all right
awesome so hello everybody thank you for
having me
uh my research project is uh
basically investigating the effects of
the onset of menopause
on the transcriptomic profile of the
aging female brain
so i am nathra srinivasan from
leland high school in san jose
california
in the u.s and i am interested in
bioinformatics because of the
flexibility
it provides to do biological research
and the interdisciplinary field of
bioinformatics allows me to
explore data and draw conclusions in a
new way
and i've been attracted to research for
years because i'm able to
learn new things hands-on and draw
conclusions from my work which is very
satisfying to me
and i look forward to the future
research
that i do as well learning from this
experience
so to start off with the significance
of the problem so we know that there is
a divergence in the occurrence of
neurodegenerative diseases between males
and females
but the mechanisms so far are unknown
so mishra it all validated the
divergence between
human males and females through
microarray profiling
but for example more than 5.5 million
americans are living with alzheimer's
disease
of whom two-thirds are elderly women
and the mitochondria of young females
are protected
against the pathologies of alzheimer's
disease
compared to males but this advantage is
lost in older females
and moreover current alzheimer's disease
treatments only target
neurotransmitters to treat the symptoms
but not the root cause and thus it's
important
to figure out the underlying factors to
be able to better target
treatment through identifying
transcriptomic differences
to identify the genes at play and
pinpoint the pathways
for treatment so previous research has
investigated immune profiles and
menopausal rats
but the overall effects are yet to be
interpreted
and so understanding the genes expressed
differently in the progressive stages
of female aging and menopause can help
us understand risks for
neurodegeneration and pathways
to treat in order to treat
neurodegeneration such as
for alzheimer's disease in women and so
through this research doctors and
researchers will be able to take
the occurrence of menopause into account
when developing
treatments for near degenerative
diseases which significantly affects
more females than males and so to
summarize current treatments only
address the symptoms
but do not target the root cause
so therefore understanding the genes
expressed differently
in the progressive stages of female
aging and menopause
can help us understand the risks for
neurodegeneration
and pathways to treat these diseases
such as
alzheimer's disease in women more
effectively
and so through understanding that the
onset of menopause plays a role in the
risks
for neurodegenerative diseases uh
possible treatments involving
estrogen or progesterone which play a
role in modulating menstrual cycles
and menopause could reverse the effects
of menopause
opening a revolutionary pathway for the
treatment of
neurodegenerative diseases
so to talk a little bit about female
aging in general
so menopause is the end of a female's
menstrual cycle and fertility in which
the
ovaries no longer produce estrogen
and progesterone so humans undergo
menopause
but another organism that also undergoes
menopause
are rats so in this uh
research project uh we use data
from rats and so they follow
the same the similar uh menopause
uh phase as humans in which first at
about
six months for rats uh they undergo
premenopause
in which they have the normal estrous
cycles and then after that the
transition to
perimenopause at around nine months in
which the cycles are real
irregular but have not completely
stopped and then after that with some
time within those nine months
they transition into menopause
and then uh at about 15 months
there at post menopause and so post
menopause in humans
is basically the year mark from the
final cycle
and so that's basically the transitional
um phases of menopause in fats
so uh for in terms of the aging of the
female brain
um so far we know that there
is as the brain ages there
is an increased immune response but we'd
like to take a look
at the overall effects
as well so to transition on to
the data set distribution uh for
my study so so far there
so in my study uh there are six groups
with six samples each so there is the
female rat
at six months which we've abbreviated as
reg six
m and then there's the female rat at
nine months
uh with the normal cycle then nine
months
with an irregular cycle nine months an
acyclic then nine months
at obx and 16 months
uh and they are acyclic
so basically the ovx
uh is important because it acts as a
control group
in which it highlights the most
important clinical features
of estrogen deficiency uh induced
or postmenopausal conditions
so um to summarize my research question
and hypothesis
so understanding the genes expressed
differently in the progressive stages of
female aging
and menopause can help us understand the
risks for neurodegeneration
and pathways to target in order to treat
neurodegeneration such as alzheimer's
disease for women
so there were a couple of questions that
came up
from this so firstly how does the age or
time of the onset of menopause affect
the transcriptomic expression
and which pathways are affected um are
there biomarkers and menopausal women
that are menopausal females that helps
us identify their risk for certain
neurodegenerative disorders
and how does the expression differ in
over-activized specimens and regular
specimens and can this lead to insights
on the onset of neurodegenerative
disease
and so then then comes my central
question
in what are the effects of the onset of
menopause on the transcriptomic profile
of the aging female brain
so for my methodology uh
i had to compare six groups
so i then used principal component
analysis
differential gene expression analysis
to identify the significant genes and i
used hierarchical clustering um
then i looked at the significantly
expressed genes and
did functional annotation on david and
and richer
to visualize the
expressed pathways or the pathways that
are upregulated and down regulated such
as neuroinflammation
or neurodegeneration etc and relating
the expression to each other to draw
conclusions
and analyze which genes are
underexpressed
or overexpressed in the six groups
so firstly um with pca i compared
the regular groups versus the acyclic
groups and the regular versus irregular
and i got these pca plots
in which there is a divergence
between the regular and acyclic and the
regular and
irregular and so what i did
is i basically for with these
um uh uh plots
i formed uh my plan for doing
differential expression in which i split
it into
regular versus acyclic and regular
versus irregular
so with further pca
using the significant genes we can see
that there
are two clusters and there's also a
divergence
between the regular groups and the
overectomized group with the two
clusters
and also through differential expression
i obtained
these two plots showing the significant
genes
and these are also other plots obtained
by differential expression
so for the path to summarize the
pathways
that were upregulated and down regulated
so for regular
versus um irregular uh
and regular versus acyclic uh the
pathways that were upregulated were
related to
the immune system and the pathways that
were down regulated
were related to the mitochondria
and neurodegenerative disorders such as
oxidative phosphorylation
alzheimer's and things like that
so they share 583 genes down regulated
and 550 genes upregulated
and so the downregulation is the
oxidative phosphorylation
um alzheimer's and parkinson's so things
related to mitochondrial dysfunction
and the pathways that are up regulated
were
zinc and metal binding which are all
related to the
immune system
so i also did hierarchical clustering
and in the dendrograms
uh we can see that they're two that the
um regular
and the acyclic groups and the regular
and irregular groups
um are separated into two clusters
showing that
they are indeed different
and also through the pathway analysis
visual
visualized um on and richer
we can see for the regular versus
irregular
which pathways are upregulated um which
are
down regulated and same thing for
regular versus acyclic which pathways
are upregulated
and which pathways um are downregulated
so for my conclusion
and discussion so
firstly i found that
uh there is a clear distinction between
the
transcriptomics of the regular rats
shifting to irregular
and acyclic phases so our analysis
clearly indicates that there's an impact
on the transcriptomics of the rat
especially in relation to the
mitochondrial function leading to near
degenerative diseases such as
alzheimer's and parkinson's disease
and thus supporting current pathologies
and so with the upregulation of
zinc regulated pathways the immune
response was heightened
um and it's also evident that menopause
and not only age is a factor
for the differential expression due to
the divergence between
the over-rectimized and the regular
groups thus controlling for age and
significant signifying
a difference between the regular and
post-menopausal conditions
and so the study sheds light on the
targeting of possible treatments for
neurodegenerative diseases caused by
oxidative stress
and through understanding that the
transitioning of menopause plays a role
in
uh exacerbating oxidative stress
damaging the mitochondria the direct
hormones modulating menopause
uh can be controlled and so once the
root cause of the oxidative stress
is removed the damaged mitochondrial
membrane actually
is able to bounce back to original
condition
which may be revolutionary for
near-degenerative recovery
the possible limitations of the study
include the sample size
and the data collection procedures which
i was unable to do myself
and it's also based on only rat samples
and it's not validated on human samples
yet
so further exploration on the lack of
estrogen and progesterone themselves
require
exploration and so that's for further
research i'd like to generate a
controlled data set
with menopausal rats supplemented with
estrogen and progesterone
to investigate the effects as well as
investigate
this phenomenon in humans
so thank you for this opportunity to
present my
project and i'm open to any questions
that you have
thank you so much nitra that was an
amazing presentation too
good work so i have one question can we
conclude from this
project that every woman who enters her
menopausal stage
would have chances of getting
neurodegenerative disorder or can we not
put it in this way
um we can say that there
is well the thing is that we can't
uh really conclude uh we can't really
say anything in conclusive terms that
every single woman because firstly this
has to be
validated um in humans because this is
this project is currently done in rats
but we can say
that there is a possible chance uh
of that phenomenon to occur and so
through doing extra uh
through doing further research on um
this phenomenon
in humans uh we might be able to make
that conclusion
thank you and also we do have one
question from
youtube online streaming uh prima is
asking that does menopause occur in all
female organisms
at some particular time or age period in
which this mechanisms take place
um i'm not sure if menopause happens
in every organism but i do know
that it happens in most mammals
and so menopause it typically
is towards the end of the
fertility cycle for
organisms that do have menopause uh
because of the general aging um so i
hope that answers
uh that question so because rats are
mammals and humans are also mammals
um menopause occurs
also we do have one more question from
zulfiqar mahdi she says you have given
the nice talk
and also can you name some noteworthy
targets with therapeutic advantage in
neurodegenerative diseases
um so so far
for neurodegenerative diseases
like for alzheimer's the way that they
treat it is
by treating the symptoms like for
example
they target acetylcholine
or dopamine but that only targets
the symptoms whereas for the
root cause which could be
related to menopause um they could
possibly
uh target the pathway involving
um estrogen and progesterone uh
modulation because with menopause
estrogen
the difference between um you know
regular cycling and in menopause is that
estrogen and progesterone
um are not produced and so
possibly um through uh adding
through adding uh estrogen and
progesterone back into the pathway
there might be some therapeutic
advantage to that
but since it hasn't been tested we don't
really know for sure
okay can it be any protein
um or gene regulation no we haven't i
haven't investigated that
in my uh study
uh thanks neeta for answering that
question uh what i think for
zulfiqar is maybe you should go through
some literature review
uh on this particular topic of neural
degeneration and protein regulation
there are many on ncbi
because this question is very broad in
itself and it just cannot be answered
from one perspective or one project of
view so that would be helpful for you i
guess and if you need some more
literature review you can surely reach
out to me i'll help you thank you
any more questions for nitro
okay if there are any more questions you
can put it down in the chat box thank
you so much naitra for sharing with us
your wonderful project
we have a lot from you to learn as well
thank you for being with us we are glad
to have you
thank you can i yeah thank you uh
sanalika
uh uh over here sodalika would tell you
about
the upcoming events and webinars from
pine bar tech
sonaliga you may share your screen thank
you
thank you so much rudy and thank you so
much
for such wonderful presentations and
showcasing your work as well i hope it
would have helped a number of people
here
to uh know more about how transcriptomic
data could be analyzed and visualized
as well so let let me just
quickly take you through our portal that
is learn.comicslogic and if you have
already signed up to the portal it's
great
if you have not done so far uh here is
the link you can
sign up now and those who have already
signed up i would request them to please
update their profile
and by updating profile i mean please
add your profile picture
and also link in your social now this is
because we want the correct name of
yours
uh in your profile because that would be
reflecting in your certificates as well
and to have your social links it's just
because we have been having recruiters
over the time and we share good profiles
with them
and also we would be featuring uh you
on your performance on over our social
so we would want your social link too
and now coming to the research
fellowship program
so nitra and urja were a part of a
research fellowship program
and they did such wonderful projects in
the program itself
so even if you wish to be a part of the
research fellowship program and carry
out your independent research
project under mental guidance you can
register yourself
on this page the link i've shared with
you all you need to do is just register
yourself
to the page and you can also go through
the page to
clear your doubts and we have answered
few frequently asked questions over here
and also we have added the
progress like what would be the steps
you would have to
follow in the research fellowship
program
and what all you would have to go
through you can go through
the program page as well and also i'm
sharing with you
a blog which you can refer to learn more
about the research fellowship program
and
also you can go through the projects as
of nathra and urja we have
other projects as well by our
ex-research fellows
so you can go to their projects as well
and learn what they did
and many of you we also give
scholarships to students who are worth
it so here is the scholarship
link i would request the students to
also fill in the scholarship application
so that we can go through your
application and
obviously give a scholarship because i
because we think those who are really
into research
and are looking forward for great
research work they should be supported
with the scholarship
so here is the form and we would be
looking forward to your registrations
and applications as well
now coming to our upcoming program that
is on precision medicine
this program would be starting on july 6
it would be a month training and would
end on august 5th
and uh we have a free webinar tomorrow
at 8 00 pm where we would be discussing
about the program we would be discussing
the session details
as well and what all would be covered
and
why this program is necessary so
those who want to learn more about the
program now and also register themselves
here is the link for you you can just go
to this program page here all the
details of the program
uh is mentioned and also the session
details
uh with their topics and what all would
be covered is mentioned in the program
page
now taking forward to the social media i
really want that we all stay connected
and also you stay updated
with all our ongoing and upcoming
programs and projects because we see
that bioinformatics is changing the
era of research and we need not miss out
on any such
opportunity which could help us learn
more about the bioinformatics tools
and also different sorts of advances in
the research
so do stay updated you can follow us on
linkedin
also they had shared the links of
our telegram and whatsapp groups so here
uh here is
the linkedin uh group link as well you
you can be a part of a group and also we
have
so many experts as part of a group so
they would be there to help you as well
and on facebook we are by the name of
pine biotech you can
follow us there as well so we have
spread all across
uh across so that you have no issue
finding us
anywhere and you can stay in touch with
us
and get updates on all our upcoming
programs
and if you have any doubts you can
anytime
mail me at marketing at the rate pine
dot
bio and i would be there to help you out
thank you so much ruthie for conducting
such a wonderful
session and we have the psionic session
every thursday
so we would be meeting you again next
thursday let's see who we have as
speakers
would be updating you all with it soon
thank you everyone for being a part of
us for the webinar
and uh those who have any doubts uh
regarding ultras or nathra's projects
you can
mail them and get in touch with them and
if
any other uh query you have regarding
the programs or the
uh the registrations or applications or
scholarships
uh your you can anytime meet
thank you so much everyone thank you
ruthvi
thank you sanadika bye
bye everyone take care bye